ja wir müssen unseren freiheits muskel
wieder trainieren denn die der
ausnahmezustand der letzten zwei jahre
mit tiefgreifenden grundrechtseingriffen
der darf nicht zur normalität werden ich
finde so laufen aber gerade die debatten
im land zum teil denn wenn wir jetzt zum
glück dafür haben wir freien demokraten
gekämpft nicht mehr eine allgemeine
masken pflicht haben dann ist das doch
kein masken verbot für alle die sich
schützen wollen und zum beispiel im
supermarkt zum eigenschutz weiter eine
ft2 maske tragen ich finde wir müssen
einfach darüber diskutieren die pandemie
ist nicht vorbei aber ihr charakter hat
sich verändert die
infektionszahlen bionicon sie sind zwar
hoch sie haben sich aber entkoppelt von
der frage der krankenhauseinweisung und
erst recht intensiv pflichtigen
patientenzahlen und da muss doch in
einem freiheitlichen staates gelten
eigenverantwortung first verbote second
es ist nicht aufgabe des staates die
allgemeinen lebensrisiken zu minimieren
in einem staat der auch ein
verantwortungs fähige bürgerinnen und
bürger von denen ausgeht und da ist im
moment viel zu tun die debatte hat sich
leider sehr verschoben sie haben völlig
recht ich möchte auch nicht in einem
land leben wo die freiheit nichts mehr
gilt dann kann ich auswandern da lebe
ich irgendwo wo ich tomatenpflanze und
jeden tag diese aber nicht mehr hier
weil ich kann in deutschland
verschiedene es nicht leiden unter
anderem den umgang mit minderheiten wie
ich jetzt gelernt habe das hätte ich nie
für möglich gehalten da müssen wir was
aufarbeiten aber ich möchte in einem
freien land leben und ich habe in den
letzten wochen und monaten beobachtet
wie auch in zeitungen
in artikeln von wissenschaftlern
historiker politologen der begriff der
freiheit zerlegt worden ist als sei der
fragwürdig als komme es darauf nicht
mehr an wer redet eigentlich heute von
freiheiten sie als liberale politiker
haben das wahrscheinlich auch beobachtet
ich bin darüber erschrocken wenn wir mal
so weit sind dass wir theoretisch
darüber reden dass wir gar keine
freiheit mehr brauchen sondern das
anderes wichtiger ist und das ist sie
haben das ja immer wieder sich anhören
müssen dass es die beschwörer der
freiheit sind die uns ins unglück führen
dann müssen wir dann wirklich dann
schrillen bei mir sämtliche alarmglocken
und dann müssen wir ja möglicherweise
gehen wir irgendwann mal auf die strasse
ich dann auch
frau geht's haben sie denn das gefühl
dass sie noch in einem freiheitlichen
land leben naja sagen wir mal so ich
habe manchmal das gefühl dass viele
sagen wir wollen unseren alten kaiser
wilhelm wiederhaben wieder diese alt
diese führungsperson die jetzt sagt wo
es langgeht und selber entscheidungen
treffen das ist dann schon schwierig und
ich möchte im moment wirklich kein
politiker sein weil egal was du machst
du kannst so viel falsch machen das fing
an mit corona die einband dafür die
entscheidungen die anderen die gegen
auch jetzt der krieg man ist dafür mann
ist dagegen es ist schwierig aber
ich finde einfach der ton muss sich
verbessern ich finde freiheit bedeutet
auch dass man den anderen die freiheit
lässt seine meinung zu äußern
und man soll sich selber auch die
freiheit geben seine meinung zu ändern
weil ganz viele halten an ihren einmal
gefassten thesen fest weil sie nicht
schwach oder oder ich habe ein schwaches
rückgrat oder ich falle um es muss sich
auf die fdp öfter mal umhören nein man
muss auch mit man muss auch sehen dass
sich zeiten ändern situationen ändern
und dann muss man flexibel im kopf sein
und umdenken man muss auch den mut haben
zu sagen damals hat es gepasst jetzt
passt es nicht mehr wir müssen jetzt mit
einer anderen weg gehen ohne angst davor
zu haben lena duos ich ich hab mal
gesagt
das recht auf irrtum gehört zur freiheit
da ich wünsche mir dass das in den
medien mal selbst kritisch diskutiert
wird was in den medien in den in den
meisten jedenfalls in den letzten
monaten alles geschrieben worden ist
über diese geschichte und was an
irrtümern verkündet worden ist und
unrecht getan worden ist gegenüber
anderen die eine andere meinung
vertreten haben man kann ja heute noch
lesen habe ich jetzt gerade in einer
großen überregionalen zeitung in einem
leitartikel das eigentlich die maske
pflicht für immer weiter gelten sollte
für ältere oder für internetzeitung was
war nun starb wieder erschrocken habe
ich auch gelesen
von bibione dass unser land verändern
wenn wir ständig wenn wir in einem
supermarkt kommen auch in drei vier fünf
jahren den maske aufziehen müssen lieber
himmel dann gehe ich hier auch gerne die
frage an freud heute denke ich habe auch
diese angst hat heute berg eine bürgerin
wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass die
masken pflicht einfach meine kleine
schwester ließen 23 hat heute ihre
letzte bwe klau so bestimmt ja und ich
habe heute morgen gesagt wie schön
endlich mal wieder eine klasse ohne
macht die gestern weil der freedom day
was am sonntag maske ist gefallen dann
guckt man spreche mich an sagt nee ich
schreibe die ganze klasse mit maske
meine schwester ist geimpft sitzt da im
einzel tisch mit abstand von dem anderen
nicht abzuschreiben und muss ihre
klausur mit maske schöpft weil hört das
thema auf also dafür haben wir gesorgt
nach dem zweiten vierten ist damit
schluss leider konnten doch leider nicht
besuchen na ja es sei
denn sie missbrauchen die hotspot
regelung und meinen sie seien ein
flächendeckender hotspot aber sie können
höchstens bis zum 24 das was sie schon
als landesregelung hatten weitergelten
lassen danach können sie das nicht mehr
als landesregelung machen wir haben das
begrenzt auf krankenhäuser pflegeheime
öffentlichen personennahverkehr man kann
nicht mehr in schulen oder am
arbeitsplatz oder im supermarkt eine
allgemeine masken pflicht verhängen die
hotspots das soll wirklich die
möglichkeit seien regional zu reagieren
aber es gibt ja leider die anzeichen
dass einige meinen sie klären einfach
mal ihr ganzes bundesland zum hotspot da
ist wachsamkeit gefordert aber daran wie
viel wie viel prügel einstecken dafür
überhaupt dafür einzustehen dass man
wenn die situation sich ändert auch die
gesetze ändern muss und dass auch die
regeln angepasst werden müssen dass das
macht mir eben wirklich sorge freiheit
wird diffamiert da wird von wohl der
liberalismus gesprochen ich würde eher
sagen wir haben ganz viel wohl der in
diesem land ja die freiheit wird
diffamiert ich habe am wochenende
gelesen der süddeutschen zeitung
suppenkasper freiheit aber nicht ein
einziges darum den euro nicht ein
argument dafür warum diese
schwerwiegenden grundrechtseingriffe die
wir uns bis vor zwei jahren nicht hätten
träumen lassen dieser republik warum die
jetzt gerechtfertigt sein zu verlängern
man wird als ungezogenes kind
dargestellt wenn man das mal in frage
steht dass sie das wort gibt nach hinten
und zieht die ganze tischdecke mit muss
und wo sind ein rechtsverteidiger die
politik nie gesagt dass jedes
kriminalitätsopfern grund sein mag zumal
überwachung zu fordern diese logik ist
gefährlich zu sagen jeder mögliche
krankheit oder todesfall rechtfertigt
jedes scharfe stattliche maße bürger
wie empfinden sie das denn hat für sie
auch die korona pandemie vielleicht auch
die staatsgläubigkeit der deutschen zum
vorschein gebracht dieses form und hafte
diesen menschen der regel macht dem man
will also ich sag mal so
auf das statement zurückzukommen
ich fühle mich immer noch frei in
deutschland trotz maske das ist für mich
jetzt nicht die alles entscheidende
schlimmste einschränkung an sich für
mich ist immer noch primär wenn die
intensivstationen
noch freie kapazitäten haben kann man
maske tragen muss es nicht mehr auf die
maske tatsächlich aber für mich jetzt
nicht so elementaren nicht so eine große
einschränkung an sich die maßnahmen
vielmehr die kann ich tatsächlich frage
stellen das ist so glaubt noch wer kommt
in dem auto bilden sie jetzt erwachsener
mann ich möchte ich fragen über fragen
möchten sie jetzt erwachsener mann dass
ihnen jemand vorgibt die entscheidung
sie tragen jetzt die maske schröder
wollen sie nicht selber also ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich fühle mich völlig ich
bin 29 jahre alt ich kann selber
entscheiden wann ich eine maske tragen
soll war nicht wann ich es tue finden
sie dass dieser form und zum beispiel
schweden hat ja nie de facto so eine
allgemeine masken pflicht und auch in
england gibt es das nicht mehr finden
sie es richtig dass ihnen der staat
vorschreibt ziehen sie die maske auf da
komme ich wieder darauf zurück von
vorhin gesagt hat
verteidigungsministerin mit erfahrungen
oder gesundheitsminister mit erfahrung
ich unterstelle grundsätzlich weil ich
den menschen ich bin gut gläubiger
mensch vom grund her und wenn man mir
sagt es hilft in der sache man kann
entweder nicht anstecken und man wird
vor allem nicht angesteckt dann habe ich
insbesondere am anfang daran geglaubt
dass es hilfreich ist ich habe am anfang
sogar die maske selbst freiwillig
getragen als noch kein impfstoff gaben
jetzt aufgrund der maßnahmen in zeitz am
flughafen darf man nicht nebeneinander
setzen und auf den toiletten männer
toiletten dann plötzlich fünf toiletten
2 und damit abgedeckt dann steht man
hintereinander geht mit diesem flugzeug
rein sitzt nebeneinander komplett mit
maske ich bestelle mir ne cola oder bier
und dann abziehen
der ist in sachen die kann natürlich
nicht nachsehen ja ich will mal was
positives erzählen moment unbedingt
keine zeit mehr frei ist ja
immer so das letzte war am samstag in
einem wochenmarkt auf renschler werk da
sind nur noch höchstens zehn prozent
obwohl der maske vorgeschrieben erhält
maske rumgelaufen die anderen haben sie
nicht mehr getragen es war ein
herrliches gefühl freiheit